y seguimos estrenando sesiones en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar muy buen
día bienvenida qué gusto tenerla en
nuestro estudio como cada viernes a
partir de hoy vamos a hablar de un tema
en profundidad vamos a empezar con el
índice de masa corporal mari cómo se
siente hoy pues bien muy contenta de
estar contigo de estar con todos ustedes
empecemos a hablar por el índice de masa
corporal cuéntame raúl alguna vez has
pasado por el mal trago de que tengan
que calcular este índice por supuesto
todos los que tenemos un poco de jarrita
hemos pasado por eso más tanto tú como
yo como muchísimas personas y eso
debería hacernos sonar ya algunas
alarmas empecemos explicando cómo se
calcula esto es una operación matemática
que se hace agarrando el peso y la
altura de una persona y el resultado nos
indica si estamos en un rango normal o
no de peso todo lo que queda entre el
18,5 y el 24,9 se considera que es un
rango de peso normal mientras todo que
todo lo que supera el 25 se considera
sobrepeso lo que supera el 30 se
considera obesidad y todo lo que queda
por debajo del 18,5 en cambios era un
peso inferior al normal estos son los
estándares que manejamos marc pero
también hay voces es cierto que critican
este indicador le pregunto cuál es la
polémica en torno a esto pues
principalmente es que se usa como una
herramienta de diagnóstico de salud
cuando en verdad es más un indicador
estadístico precisamente de eso hablamos
con la doctora paola sabogal ella es
nutricionista y la entrevistamos
previamente en france 24 esto fue lo que
nos dijo creo que desde los
determinantes sociales de salud y de
todo lo que sabemos hoy en día el índice
de masa corporal no podría ser un
criterio ni siquiera acertado creería yo
para para poder identificar o
diagnosticar la salud de las personas
porque la salud es supremamente
multifactorial y reducirla al peso que
tiene una persona es totalmente
desacertado al final el índice de masa
corporal raúl no tiene en cuenta cosas
como por ejemplo la distribución de la
grasa no tiene en cuenta cosas como la
raza la etnia de una persona tampoco su
género por ejemplo y eso hace que
corporalidad es distintas no siempre
encajen dentro de estos estándares
además no tiene en cuenta indicadores de
salud y básicos también para conocer el
estado de una persona como el colesterol
la glucosa la presión arterial
muchísimas cosas que nos hablan más que
una simple cita que incluso es más
importante lo que tenemos adentro que
pues el nivel de masa corporal que
podemos tener nosotros más pero si tiene
todos estos problemas porque se sigue
usando pues de hecho se sigue usando
porque es una cosa muy fácil de calcular
cualquier persona lo puede hacer en casa
en las consultas médicas y sirve como un
primer cribaje para identificar algunos
riesgos así lo describe el centro para
control y prevención de enfermedades de
eeuu luego lo describen como un
indicador válido para prever futuras
muertes para prever futuras enfermedades
eso sí siempre reconociendo que debe
combinarse con otros factores para hacer
una evaluación completa del estado de
salud de una persona pero bueno raúl hay
buenas noticias y es que esta
correlación no siempre es cierta según
un estudio publicado en 2016 por el
international journal of obesity la
mitad de las personas que ellos
estudiaron que estaban caracterizadas
como personas con sobrepeso en realidad
estaban perfectamente sanas lo mismo
ocurría con un cuarto de las personas
caracterizadas
como obesas y todo esto mientras un
tercio de las personas consideradas
normales de peso pues en verdad no
estaban bien de salud cuando se tenían
en cuenta otros indicadores así es más
entonces no me puedo preocupar tanto por
lo que está diciendo usted qué
consecuencias tiene usar mal este
indicador me imagino que muchas no es
una buenísima pregunta y de hecho
también se le decimos a la doctora
sabogal ella se los va a contar mucho
mejor que yo
yo creo que en últimas está el hecho de
que se nos pueden pasar por alto muchas
enfermedades reales en las personas que
suelen no ser atendidas porque siempre
lo que más se critica o lo que más se
cuestiona desde las personas gordas a
los profesionales de salud es que yo
puedo llegar con cualquier dolencia pero
como mi índice de masa corporal sale por
encima de 30 entonces lo que me mandan
inmediatamente es tienes que perder peso
y no se atiende a la dolencia de base
entonces creo que ese es uno de los más
importantes también por supuesto los
trastornos de la conducta alimentaria
que vienen en un aumento importante y
que son las enfermedades de salud mental
con mayor riesgo de mortalidad y creo
que eso es supremamente importante así
que quizás una de las primeras cosas que
deberíamos hacer es dejar de asumir que
porque una persona esté con sobrepeso o
esté haga sea gorda no está sana no hay
muchísimos factores que influyen al
final en la salud y raúl definitivamente
los estigmas o los prejuicios no
deberían ser uno de ellos y marc lo
mejor siempre es ir siempre al médico
para saber de primera mano lo que
podemos tener o no muchísimas gracias
nos vemos el lunes con más salud en
directo américa a ustedes con nosotros